歡迎回來趙花
歡迎說
我要問艾倫喔
如果今天一檔股票啊
出事情啊
就像今天我們創反彈高
創新高的公司就不用數了
可是如果他今天是打到跌停
或者是說好像今天星星好了
你敢減嗎
不敢
真的嗎
對啊
很多公司怎麼開玩法
說變法會
跌停版你敢減嗎
不會
但有遇過買了之後變法會了
你說賭他會好
結果變法會嗎
就是他也講得好
但市場就是
我大家都知道好了嘛
一例多一出來
就直接全部倒給你
那你會怎樣 例如誰
那是鼻子摸摸啊
之前有出幾個市的嘛
像這次星星減掉進去嘛
其實上個月
上上個月
也有一個被沖減掉的
是齊邦嘛 對啊
可是一看十年前的事情
那怎麼辦
股價也是回不去了
對啊 所以我在他出事的時候
我通常都不會急著想要進場
是 好啦
有因應
你是出事的時候會落跑的
那我們找出事的時候會去救他
我們先來歡迎他
就是我們的救火王
我們的玄谷教練
黃金右下角維泰
趙華好 阿倫好 大家好
真的 維泰有發現一件事嗎
就大家就找你來的時候
趙華就會講說
今天那個法會
不是啦 法說變法會的
叫維泰處理
因為有很多次
中頂工程出包
光寶科被外資降頻
旺系前兩天連續的跌停
我們每一次都會說
這一題分給維泰
救火 救火
真的太榮幸了
而且維泰都不會拒絕
他都會幫我們講出一朵花來
好 為什麼呢
因為維泰有練過
永春雙拳是真的有練過嗎
我有練過永春拳
我的老師是盧文錦老師
然後盧文錦老師是葉問的外甥
對 是
所以他的秘訣是什麼
永春的心法很多
像我們這邊跟大家分享的
就是兩個
一個叫做追影不追手
追隱不追手
对
那这个可能就跟刚刚
赵娃所提到
当一些好公司
碰到坏事情的时候
这时候我们会去看一下
这家公司
他的体质
是不是有受到影响
是
对
那么这个在我们
在令咏春群的时候
我们是说
我们会看着这一个对手
他的这个形体
而不是去看他的手
他要怎么样去挥动
这个我懂这个我懂我看着你的形体不是看著你的手我看你的形體不是體因為基本上是要打到對方的人我們不是要打對方的手
甚至不會去
特別去接對方的手
對 這個就是
追影不追手的一種
永存心法
然後運用在這個
股票市場上面
終於聽懂了
第二句也很懸
高腳但是不過膝
膝不是很低嗎
永存懸的踢法
就是高腳不過膝
怎麼踢
踢他下盤
這個有會跟踢他下盤
沒有錯
打他下盤
不是要去他中路嗎
也是
切中路的概念就是
我們投資要切到那個
盤面上面的主流
要切他中路
所以其實我覺得
永春心法裡面有非常多
非常多跟這個投資哲學有關
那麼高腳不過溪這件事情
其實大概有兩種說法
相傳在很久之前
少林寺五梅師太下山
他去教那個嚴永春
教他這個拳法的時候
因為這個嚴永春他是女生
那女生就像趙華這樣
穿著漂亮的長裙
那在教他這個腿法的時候
他不方便踢得高
所以五梅師太就教他專踢
就是所謂的下盤
下山路的一個腿法
那所以传到后面
我们就有听到
就是永春拳的这个脚法
是不会踢高的
那么在第二种说法呢
就是说在实物上
假设我们脚踢得高
踢到这个膝盖以上的话
很可能会发生就是
我们的脚被对方的手
抱住的情况
然后我们脚呢
只要被对方的手抱住
对方一拉
我们人就会跌倒
所以其实在实战上面来讲
我们的确针对这个
所谓的踢脚
我们的确是踢不过人家的膝盖
好 所以难怪叫黄金右下角
就是整个人要先稳
对不对
当我们遇到像公司跌停什么
大家都是慌
可是维泰就可以看到影是什么
然后高脚不过膝
知道它是不是一个好的买点
突然之间觉得顿悟了
突然是有道理的
OK
这么突然了吗
因为维泰之前
幫我們見檢過的公司非常的多
例如說光寶科
可能最近的都還不算是最新的我印象最深就是光寶科100塊還在被外資降頻那時候也是請維泰來講怎麼100塊了還在降頻還有近期就是世新KY
也是這個法說會後被打下去
那到底要怎樣做到追影不追手
當然今天和昨天
大家最關注的就是星星
所以今天沒有在打跌停
對你來說是一個什麼樣的位階
好 當時呢
在這個跟大家分享光寶客的時候
那個時候是在籌資
那那個籌資的過程當中
其實如果說是用憲政來看的話
本來賣壓就會比較重
因為那個時候其實會有很多的
所謂賣勞股 認新股的賣壓產生
那麼股價就掉了下來
那這時候剛好碰到這個外資
在這邊去做賣潮
所以呢這時候我就覺得
那個時候其實對公司的本質來說
應該是沒有太大的影響
反而呢他未來為了要去做籌資
他一定會想辦法再把這個股價
穩在一定的一個目標區之上
OK
所以當時光寶哥就在第一檔
跟大家做了一個分享
這還是比較近期
就今年3月24號
我講的100塊是更之前
所以你救過他
你雪山上救過好幾次光寶哥
終於有報恩的了
對
所以光寶哥現在看起來的確就是
反映我們剛剛跟大家分享的
就是他基本上他的一個本質
在這個包括Power Supply
跟這AI伺服器的一個電源
上面來講
他現在是頸椎一哥
頸椎台達電
那最近的股价也是开始
有比较明显往上去做走高
好 但是如果走到这样的阶段
不需要你救了
会不会反而会去继续看
其他的黄金右下角
我认为其实在
已经涨上去的个股
如果说没有出现败向的话
基本上我们就持股
就也不太需要出现
太明显的就是出托的动作
那的确是可以把一些
我们的精神去看待其他的
值得我们去做关注的
右下角股票
好 那另外的话
我們也可以看到就是世新KY
其實今天盤面上IP股
也是顯學
因為有這個
典發哥跟輝達
那時候講也是
兩根大黑K價來講的
利多便利空
你有講到說
欲加之罪何患無辭
對 當時是因為大家在憂鬱
他的這個毛利率
會下滑的一個情況
可是本來在做
Turnkey的一個業務
他的比重一旦拉高
他勢必營收會增加沒有錯
但是他的毛利率會下滑
但是等到下一個案子來的時候
他開始去收前期的權利金的時候那個時候毛利率就會起來這我覺得在整個架構來看基本上它對它整體的一個毛利率來講並沒有說出現明顯惡化
所以當時市場上面
反映這樣子的利空消息的時候
我倒認為說其實
搞不好會是一個
蠻不錯的一個買點
好 就是這個利空
是因為毛利率不如預期
但之後就好啦
對 想法是這樣子
那接下來就是
盡期的 盡期的新興
要是你的話會怎麼樣決定
要不要買星星
我會等事件落幕再說
是
因為這一次有提出來的狀態是
PCB的狀態
跟ABF沒有關係
但目前來說
他們好像來調查中的話
我可能就不會在現在去積極進場
那維泰的想法呢
今天土陽對坐
對
基本上如果說
看它的基本面來講的話
ABF載板
事實上的星星店
在我們這個
宰版四雄當中
的確它的一個
比重是比較高
是 沒錯
大概在超過這個65%
然後再來它的產能
或者規模
或者是它的整個技術
基本上都是領先
其他的一個同業
那只不過現在大家
比較關心的
就是說它的資本支出龐大
未來可能這個費用會增加
或者是現在有些司法上
查核的一個問題
但整體來看
我們來看一下它的一個
財務面的部分
上半年的EPS來看
它賺11.7元
這基本上也是四雄當中
算是比較好的
那法人顧它全年EPS
也是四雄當中比較好的
那唯獨就是在本益比的部分
因為它這個EPS高
那大家都覺得它好
所以股價稍微漲比較多一點點
那麼如果說從整個
籌碼面來講的話
它的這個董監跟外資
這加加起來將近有50%
那麼雖然說它沒有像是台售一樣
這個董監有61%
但整體來看我個人認為
它在整個籌碼的集中度來講
也還算是高的
所以基本上在基本面跟營運面
還有在籌碼面的部分來看
我都覺得它還是一家
值得長期投資的公司
不過剛剛艾倫也有提到
它會比較著眼於
司法調查中就好像有點不明朗
這個你會列入考量嗎
我會列入考量
那由於現在的狀況
其實就是
大家會關心說
那會不會有這個
擴大調查的一個情況
那如果擴大調查的情況之下
當然他的
所以不確定因素
可能還會持續的維持一段時間
但是呢
只要它不確定因素
維持一段時間
造成股價更下跌的話
我反倒認為它越跌
反而越是它投資價值浮現的時間點
韋太斯講的很肯定的
也不像我們都模棱兩可
想要回避這問題
沒有開玩笑
因為今天是報了一個大量
9萬多張
承接的意願很重
今天這個地方爆9萬多張
是有它的一個原因的
我們來看一下
因為今天的價格
剛剛好是回測到
之前在6月底的時候
當時這個地方有一個
7萬多張的大量
對耶
所以它其實是一個
同位量的概念
這個價格呢
對過來剛好就是
今天早上開盤的一個位置點
所以在這個位置點
似乎有一個
所謂看不見的手
去進行防守跟支撐
所以我覺得今天爆到量
是合理的
但是爆完大量之後
也就是明天跟後天就特別重要
因為這個爆量
看起來就是土陽對坐
因為今天的外資
持續站在這個買方
但是投信這邊
有出現一點轉賣的一個情況
那這時候就要去評估
這個投信的轉賣
是不是因為基金公司他們的內規
他針對某一些
他們過去認定的一些
例如說可能有法律訴訟
相關的議題的公司
他們不要碰
或者是呢就是
例如說像是其他的一些
下跌或是是有一些不確定因素
他們必須要去做一個
減碼跌一個操作
所以也未必是這個投信
他們真心想要去做賣出
那麼像今天下午
我看了一份就是人家整理的報告
就是包括像主動式基金
各個主動式基金
對於這個新興店
在這次事件他們的一個評估
基本上都還是支持新興店的
其實外資第一天就都停了
可是因為我們知道
那是外資啊
我們要看自己家投信
沒錯
但自己家投信
也沒有說大賣特賣這樣的狀況
對 那同時在這個融資的部分
反而趁著這次
這個股價下跌的融資
被洗出去一些
所以反而覺得接下來如果說
這個股價在這邊
再稍微去做一個震盪一下
然後使得融資再進一步的
去進行所謂的一個
出廠動作的話
那搞不好這一波的一個風波過去之後股價有可能就是換手然後再往上去挑戰新高是 好哇塞 這個我在講的超級明確好 追隱不追手 對不對
再來就是高腳不過膝
這邊的話我們之前
也有幫雙紅講過
非常多次的話
他現在這個腳應該過膝了
過頭了 對
長新也是從低檔講到高
所以到底下一個
可以出腳的目標在哪裡
我们现在来看一下双红
真的被讲起来了
当时讲双红的时候
我应该是跟大家分享说
这个地方是一个W底
是一个双脚底的概念
而且双脚底完之后
它就回撤
没错 双脚底
它就回撤这个颈线位置
所以当时我认为说
它的一个底部的一个形态
已经算是很明确的
然后再来呢
大物的持股比例
有在往上做增加
所以包括像是这个技术面
或者是筹码面
基本上都有利于多方发展
好 真的救下来
因为这边真的是双脚底
没有看也知道好厉害
而且重点是
它的7月份营收是创新高的
所以是委屈的
这从营收来看
长新化工也是讲在
这讲到最低一点
近期最低一点
年限的位置
投信买到现在没有认赔
融资反而去下降
对 所以这边可以观察到
投信这边持续做买超
融资持续的再去做一个减肥的动作
那当然这个当时前
可能对于这个季线
有点所谓富瓜里
富瓜里比较大的情况之下
所以这个地方
比较不见大家去进行这个杀地
好 但是现在都是在头上了
而且头信还在买
头信反而买盘的力道还加大
对 因为头信对于这种
所谓的传产股
他们的这个主要
通常都不会排在优先顺序上面
对 所以我觉得这个部分
终究当大家这个
再回头去审视
哪些个股直接做投资
哪些个股它有后市的一个
展望比較好的情況之下
我相信長期應該都是會被選上的
好 這個半導體電子級材料
最近有好幾檔
例如說中華化也很猛
所以剛剛講的都是
維泰為什麼當初敢在低檔講他們的
那現在還有這些在低檔的
一看就覺得沒信心
但維泰要加持他們是有信心的
對 會讓大家沒有信心的原因
可能我自己都會有點點就是
concent 例如說他前七月份營收
有一些還呈現這個小幅度衰退
剛剛那個不一樣
對 這個其實跟大家在
喜歡挑選這個成長股的邏輯是不一樣的因為對我來講呢這個股價值得投資必須是第一個它股價有落底跡象
然後呢
它的基本面呢
可能最快時間已經過去
基本面是往上的
那當然就像剛剛那個
常興一樣
它的整個大陸的持股
是往上做增加
刷紅也是
所以基本上呢
在這個符合這三個條件裡面
來看的話
有些個股呢
的確是我最近有在做關注
包括像是東元
然後原百 中株KY
序準 群光跟免食KY等等
他們的400商的持股
大戶的持股基本上都很高
所以在這種所謂的
大戶的持股比例相對比較高
再加上未來他們各個公司
他們的一個基本面都有出現
就是好轉情況之下
我覺得這些公司
大家可以特別做留意
好 我們等一下就
一個線圖一個線圖來看
看看觀眾朋友
你能不能有信心
D檔好歹還是電子股
UPS的續準
對 其實續準之前
我們在D檔
是有曾經跟大家分享過
那個時候其實它還沒有往上漲
還沒有往上漲
它是UPS的一個ODM龍頭
那基本上它在這個不斷練系統
它算是非常非常的專業
OK 那主要的這個題材
當然就是說未來在這個
所謂PowerRack
有可能會直接跟這個
AI Server去做分開
那麼對於虛準來講
他們本來就在做這個 UPS 相關的系統
所以對於所謂的一個從這個
這個交流電轉為直流電這塊
他算是非常的在行
所以未來在 HVDC 的部分
我覺得他是非常有機會去拿到這個訂單
那麼在第二季 EPS 已經來到了 8.12 元
那麼上半年就已經來到 12.58 元
算是一個股本
那接下來在這個下半年進入到所謂傳統的一個旺季
所以我认为说它后市的一个展望
应该是看好的
那同样的在低档的过程当中
看到它的大物池股是往上在做增加的
那目前的股价量缩稳
在这个月线跟季线的一个位置点
似乎在等一个利基点去做个发动
是不是跟那一根大量的位置
其实价钱差不多
没有错
这个赵华说得非常的一个精准
这个大量点的位置呢
换手区的位置
刚好就在每一次拉回不被跌破的地方
所以看得出來
在之前去做布局的這些人
他到目前為止都還沒有走是 好 雖然是千金谷但是這個有神秘的手撑在一千元大关我看大户持股跌下来都没有减少对啊 还越来越多
非常有信心
买个零股吗
好
好 这个我看看观众朋友
是不是反应就会开始怀疑起来了
怀疑是不是
你看躺成那样
躺成这样
它是这个群光
群光也不是不熟了
全球这个电脑周边您组建
是
在過去我們說的所謂的鍵盤
或者是甚至滑鼠
很多都是他們的
那雖然說大家覺得這個
沒有什麼成長
但是其實它在今年的第二季
稅後存益基本上還不錯
季增年增EPS 3.06
那上半年第一季加第二季
總共合計了EPS 5.06元
它是連續三年上半年
都賺超過半個股本
OK
那它的一個轉機
當然就是我個人會是
落在这个他转投资的群电
群电
群电基本上在做这个
Power Support的部分
也算是做得相当相当好
那么从去年开始
他在做这个所谓的高压的部分
也有做到一些
蛮不错的一个成绩
所以我认为说
在这个群光目前的股价
第一个
他有进行往下去
做拉回跟修正
那么在这个地方
横盘一段时间
应该是有机会去进行这个打底
那重点是呢
在打底过程当中
这个外资也没有闲着
外资反而趁着它在低档的时候
积极在做布局
所以我觉得目前看起来
群光它的整个的一个股价
应该是有机会在这边去做落地
那么接下来如果说
它的这个子公司群电
有一些好消息的话
那它的一个股价
应该也会跟着往上再做走高
好 不过群光群电
就让人家觉得是因为
消费性电子的比重太高了
好像没有办法跟AI做直接联想
这个你会评估吗
我个人认为会评估
但是它的那一块
比较是属于成长性的部分
那像我们会比较先优先
考虑到它下挡风险
只要下挡风险
我们能够可以做一个
这个cover的话
我们接下来就会期待
它这些所谓的转机
有没有机会去做一个发酵
曾经在高股息的时代
群光也是很夯的
涨到200多块
其实获利跟现在没有差异
是
好
那么再来这一个是东元
我想東元大家應該也都蠻熟悉的
它本來在做這個馬達
然後重電
但是後來它切入到了
所謂的模組化的數據中心
其實未來
〔此段辨識失敗，約 20:00 起〕